so this is really funny this is another
example
of controversy where there actually
isn't any controversy
fox news ran an explosive
headline yesterday called democratic
senator caught
on hot mike explaining
how dems will fast-track infrastructure
uh-oh what happened what sort of
devious tactic or plan
do democrats have to get infrastructure
done
this is all about democratic senator ben
cardin
ben cardin was speaking to
transportation secretary pete budej
about joe biden's infrastructure plan
and ben
cardin was caught it was a hot mic
guys he had no idea he was being
recorded
he was caught saying democrats
will use budget reconciliation
to get infrastructure reform done
requiring only a simple majority in the
senate
instead of 60 votes yeah now you might
say
hold on a second sir david we've
expected democrats to have to do that
all along
because republicans are and have been
and will continue to be total
obstructionists there will
there will be no way to get
infrastructure done without using budget
reconciliation
why is this news that ben cardin is
saying this and that is exactly the
right reaction if that is your reaction
ben cardin was caught on a hot mic
saying something that we already knew
and expected and which bernie sanders
actually
said publicly here's the big explosive
hot mic moment take a listen
okay one point so we'll figure it out
all year
some round there's certain parts of it
but ultimately it's going to be put
together similar to how
most likely happens reconciliation
so there is ben cardin saying hey pete
we're going to have to do this like the
coveted relief bill via budget
reconciliation
where's the scandal like what choice do
democrats have
when republicans won't vote for anything
at all
and in fact bernie sanders the funniest
part is
you don't have to have a hot mic bernie
said this on february 24th
it's public record axios reported on
february 24th that quote
senator bernie sanders told axios on
tuesday he's consulted with the white
house
about how to prepare for the next round
of spending and he's ready to do it
immediately
via reconciliation a process he controls
as chair of the senate budget committee
there is no story here okay
joe biden said he wants to do
infrastructure
got it we desperately need to do
infrastructure spending
okay infrastructure spending is popular
with the american people
good donald trump also promised to do
infrastructure
endlessly and he never did it so it's
overdue
and fox news is reporting as some kind
of
scandal what the obvious
publicly acknowledged strategy is going
to be
on getting infrastructure spending done
which ben cardin
said to transportation his
transportation secretary pete budej
that given republicans plan to keep
obstructing
we are going to have to do it via budget
reconciliation this
scandal is arguably less controversial
even than when barack obama wore a tan
suit and i would even go as far as to
say and some of you may disagree
this is less of a scandal than when
barack obama asked for brown mustard on
a hamburger
i'm i'm actually willing to go out and
say it is it is less
explosive even than that so we've talked
about this we did a
we talked about this yesterday there's
two different things going on
number one joe biden is really boring
that's
true and it's a welcome change in many
ways
the press briefings aside from the sort
of weird questions
from fox news reporters the press
briefings with jen saki
are boring from a sort of salacious
entertainment sense but they are
substantive and the right
absolutely hates this because there's
just no scandals
so they're manufacturing things ben
cardin caught on a hot mic
joe biden hasn't done a press conference
for 55 days i actually
this is even funnier this morning fox
apparently
now that joe biden has announced a press
conference for next week
fox news had to up their ante so this
morning i saw
a a graphic which was something like
joe biden hasn't done a press conference
for 89 days
if you include the 2020 campaign before
he was even president
mr potato head kermit the frog
pepe le pew speedy gonzalez you know all
this
this is what they are now focused on
because they don't know what to do
absent scandal when the things that joe
biden has done so far
primarily at the top of the list the 1.9
trillion dollar coveted relief bill
are popular even with republicans to a
great degree
i would expect more of this although my
my prediction would be
fox news max and oan us are sort of
going to find their lanes right now
they're kind of fumbling around in
the dark for like what's the way we can
get the most clicks based on this
administration
i think they'll figure it out and
they'll settle into something probably
within the next few months
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video